Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank"...
Next time someone asks you
to take a bite
out of a frozen pizza,
forget about it!
‐Ohh!
‐[ Laughs ]
Sugar is sneaky.
It hides in the most
innocent‐looking places.
No!
No!              No!
Don't do it!
Woman: This is Mission Control.
How do you read?
We've encountered
disruptive life‐forms.
[ Laughter ]
We're quite literally throwing
the biggest pool party
the world has ever known,
and you're all invited.
I'm not getting in
with that guy.
Cuban: [ Laughs ]
Oh!
Robert, Robert,
lift that off the counter!
Watch out! You're
burning the counter!
Herjavec: [ Shrieks ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a healthier option for kids.
♪♪
Got a bad feeling
about this one.
[ Laughter ]
Hello.
My name is Ashi Jelinek,
and I am seeking $200,000
for 8% equity
in my company, KidsLuv.
This is my son, Phoenix.
My kids are my world,
and keeping Phoenix
and his siblings healthy
is a top priority of mine.
And as a parent, we all know
how difficult it can be
to make sure your kids
are eating well.
There is sugar in everything!
And sugar is sneaky.
It hides in the most
innocent‐looking places,
like juice.
Most juices on the market have
upwards of 25 grams of sugar.
Wow.
If you were to give
your kid
an 8‐ounce glass of juice
every day for a year,
you would be giving them
20 pounds of sugar!
No!
No!              No!
[ Laughs ]
Oh!
Corcoran: Don't do it!
[ Laughs ]
Oh, no! Oh!
Oh, Phoenix, you are
sugar‐coated, my friend.
I knew I had to give him
something better,
and that's why
I created KidsLuv.
Okay, Phoenix,
get into position.
KidsLuv has this much sugar.
[ Laughter ]
O'Leary: Yeah!
Gotcha!
KidsLuv has no sugar!
But you know what it does have?
Vitamins and minerals ‐‐
all 12 essential ones.
I've created the first
zero‐sugar functional drink
for kids
that has certified
vegan vitamins and hydration.
Kids love it,
and parents do, too.
So, who wants to help me
spread the love?
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Let's try it.
Jelinek:
I have samples for you to try.
Good job, Phoenix!
‐Bye, Phoenix!
‐Outstanding performance.
‐Whoo!
[ Laughter ]
"See ya, guys!"
Here you go.
Both flavors.
Here you go, Lori.
So, mango.
And coconut.
Thank you, Robert.
For you.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Mr. Wonderful.
O'Leary:
Thank you, thank you.
Corcoran: Thank you so much.
Cuban: Thanks, Ashi.
Here you go.
O'Leary: Ashi, tell us
what we have here.
Jelinek: So, we have
our two flavors as of now.
It's Flying Fla‐mango
and Starstruck Coconut.
Cute name.
Alright.
And what is
the sweetening ingredient
that is replacing the sugar?
So, that's my secret recipe.
Wow.
It's my trade secret.
Herjavec: Oh.
That's really good.
But it is a combination...
This one's really good.
...of coconut water, juice,
a little bit of regular water,
and then I sweeten it
to cover the vitamins
with less than .1 grams
of stevia.
Not bad. Hmm.
What's really amazing
is that it is
only 10 calories.
I know. [ Chuckles ]
I can really taste
the stevia, though.
Is that real coconut water?
I can really taste it.
That's the aftertaste, right?
Yeah.
‐It's really delicious.
‐And so...
This, like,
dries your tongue.
...you can taste the stevia,
but basically,
I tried to formulate
without the stevia,
and then you get the back taste
of vitamins,
and so ‐‐
O'Leary: And are
the kids pushing back
on the stevia aftertaste
or not?
No. Most kids
don't notice that.
Your messaging around cane sugar
is definitely on trend
because even adults ‐‐
Yes.
How do I keep
this Adonis body?
[ Laughter ]
I just don't drink
any sugar.
Ashi, where are you
selling it at?
So, I'm selling right now
in independent grocery stores
in California.
It is shelf‐stable, but ‐‐
For how long?
A year.
A year?
Yeah.
Greiner: I'd love to hear
your background.
Yeah. So...
Tell us about you.
I, um, was actually ‐‐
This was not my background,
doing beverage.
I worked in the hotel business
before.
So, how did you know
to create a formula?
Where did you go to do that?
So, at first, I started trying
to do it in my kitchen,
which was very not successful.
[ Laughs ]
How do you find vitamins?
Some of these vitamins
are not soluble vitamins.
Jelinek: So, I was calling up ‐‐
Right, so I found a formulator
that helped me work
on this product.
It took me a year
to create the product,
it took me a lot of time
to develop the flavors.
These are the first two flavors.
We have another two flavors
that are ready to go.
Do you have any sales?
So, since February 2018,
I've only sold $55,000.
Packaging is ready to go ‐‐
How much money
did you have to put in
just for those two flavors?
Give or take,
like $150,000, $200,000.
Whoa!
Wow.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait.
There's no such thing
as "give or take,
$150,000 or $200,000."
Yes.
'Cause that's a big delta.
I'm just questioning your
understanding of the numbers
and how important
you make money,
considering you're asking
for our money.
Yes, I understand that.
Right, so how m‐‐
So, he's just saying, which one
was it, $150,000 or $200,000?
So, it was probably
close to $200,000.
And where did you get
the $200,000,
and how much all‐in
have you invested so far?
So, so far, I have done
a family‐and‐friends round
of financing
on a $3.5 million
convertible note.
‐Wow.
Jelinek: Capped post money.
Corcoran: You must
have rich friends.
How much did you raise?
$1 million.
Ohh!
$1 million?
Yes.
Wow!
I know that sounds
like a lot ‐‐
Yes, it's a lot!
O'Leary: Wow!
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but they are shocked
by how much Ashi has raised
bringing her healthier
juice alternative for kids,
KidsLuv, to market.
How much did you raise?
$1 million.
Ohh!
$1 million?
Yes.
Wow!
I know that sounds
like a lot ‐‐
Yes, it's a lot!
O'Leary: Wow!
Yes, it is,
but it's taken a lot
for me to come up with
the vegan vitamins to source it.
I am in talks right now
with one big‐box
national retailer to do a test.
Okay, so, how much cash do you
have left in the bank?
What ‐‐ What did he ‐‐
I have $50,000
left in the bank.
$50,000?!
‐Yes.
‐Out of the million?
‐Whoa.
Ohh, Ashi!
You burned through $950,000?
So I want to explain that.
How did you burn $950,000?
Yikes!
Jelinek:
So, it's been 3 1/2 years
that I have been working
on this.
Okay.
Where did the bulk
of the $950,000 go?
So, regulatory.
What is that? Lawyers?
Okay, so ‐‐ so ‐‐ Yes.
What did you spend
the money on?
So I did international, um,
licensing,
and international I. P.
[ Groans ]
Corcoran: Oh, my God.
Herjavec: And what did
that cost you?
And national I. P.
What did you spend
on that?
A lot.
So, on that, I spent
around...$150,000.
Ohh! Oh!
$150,000.
So I have all that done,
though.
I've trademarked
the name KidsLuv,
as well as
the parent‐company name,
which is
The Luving Company.
Ashi, just listening
to this is so painful.
Then I paid for my ‐‐
But I paid for my
manufacturing run, as well.
It's just ‐‐
There was one thing ‐‐
How much did you pay for
a manufacturing run?
It is painful.
Jelinek: ...that I just did.
So, I just finished a run,
and I spent, um, $57,000
on the run,
because it's Tetra Pak.
My plan and why I'm here
is to really focus
on West Coast right now
and then duplicate that plan
to other coasts
in a very strategic pattern
following where
my demographics are.
No, I got it.
That sounds very fancy,
but where are you gonna get
the money to do any of that?
Well, so, right now,
I'm also in the process
of talking
to my current investors
about putting money into
basically track me,
where we are ‐‐
And what do your
original investors say
going back to them
for more money?
Are they eager
to lend it?
You know, now that I'm ‐‐
finally have gotten
distribution in order,
and I'm ready to be in stores ‐‐
[ Chuckles ]
Ashi,
listen to me a minute.
You did all of that
and spent all of that money
before you found out
the most important component,
which is, can it sell?
How fast can it sell?
How much of it can I sell?
Okay, so, I am
at that point now
that I have my distribution
in lock.
I understand that I spent money.
I am totally willing
to own my mistakes
and ways
that I could've saved ‐‐
No, but here's the rub.
You're not owning
your own mistakes, really.
The investors
that gave you their money
are really owning
your mistakes.
And then you come here,
and you're asking us
to follow your other investors
down that little yellow path.
Well ‐‐
It makes absolutely no sense.
So ‐‐
It's amazing to me
that you don't see
what's wrong with that picture.
For all of those reasons,
I'm out.
Cuban:
Yeah, Ashi, I mean,
the one thing that you
haven't owned up to
is saying that you're
going door to door.
And I understand
it's tough for the family.
But I am.
I'm doing grassroots
marketing efforts ‐‐
Marketing is not sales.
Marketing is trying
to create demand
so that there's sell‐through
at some point.
But I am selling the product.
What I had to do in order
to get it to the market
is to come up with a strategy,
and, unfortunately,
I did not plan
on that the distribution
was going to take
this long to lock down.
Again, you say
the word "distribution."
Yeah.
I didn't say
"distribution."
You're just talking
about me doing it.
Yes!
Whose company is it?
Mine.
Who's responsible for it?
Me.
Who should be doing
all the selling?
Me.
That's what I'm doing now.
No.
Going out and getting
a distributor
is not doing
all the selling.
For those reasons,
I'm out, Ashi.
Okay.
I wish you all the best.
Okay, thank you.
O'Leary: This idea has merit,
but we need sell‐through data,
because I don't know
if the kids are gonna love it.
I don't know because
I don't see re‐orders
through the distribution
you have yet.
So, we are online.
Thrive Market,
in the last six months,
has reordered every month.
We have sold out so many times
that I actually have
out‐of‐stock problems
in the flavors ‐‐
Well, look,
that's encouraging,
but I don't want to take
this journey with you.
I just can't do it.
I'm out. I'm sorry.
Okay.
Herjavec:
Ashi, I have to tell you,
I admire how much
you're standing your ground.
You've made mistakes.
Everybody here makes mistakes.
The problem is, cash is
the lifeblood of the business.
Agreed.
Once you run out of cash,
you're dead.
You've learned the theory
of great business plans.
With all due respect,
honestly ‐‐
But you're not ‐‐
But Thrive Market, I am getting
the reorders, and I am there.
But you're not fighting
in the trenches.
You're not out there
selling it, hand by ‐‐
I am.
That's all I'm doing.
I have three little kids
at home,
and I'm the person hopping on
the plane to sell the product.
But you've also burnt through
$950,000...
I do not
sound the brokers there.
...in order to get here.
That's against
$55,000 coming in.
Ashi, I'm sorry, I ‐‐
It makes me nervous
about giving you more money.
I'm out.
Listen, you went through
the process
of trying to over‐protect,
patent everywhere.
It cost you a fortune,
and that was
a big hole for you,
because the bottom line is,
you didn't even know
if your product
would sell well.
I feel that,
while I liked the product,
you got into that trap.
But unfortunately,
as an investor,
I wouldn't want
to be involved with it.
And I'm sorry.
I hope you do well.
Thank you.
But I'm out.
O'Leary:
I blame you for it.
You made a huge mistake.
I'm sorry. It's just,
the numbers don't lie.
Good luck.
Thank you.
We wish all our entrepreneurs
good luck...
Thank you.
...but you've got
a wall to climb.
Cuban: Good luck.
Thank you so much.
I feel like I did
get a little beat up.
I think that, you know, because
the Sharks got so hung up
on the money that I've raised,
they didn't see the true value
of KidsLuv,
and unfortunately,
because of that,
they're obviously
not the right investors.
That was a huge mistake
on the patent side.
I got to tell you,
when it's my money
and I lose it, I feel bad.
Oh!
But when I take
a dollar from you...
Somebody else.
...that is ‐‐
I wake up every day
to give you your money back.
Yes.
And she didn't even
feel bad about it.
♪♪
Narrator: In Season 9,
Julia Cheek made a deal
with Lori Greiner
for her at‐home lab‐testing kit,
EverlyWell.
I would like to take
a flier on you.
Let's see how EverlyWell
is doing now.
"Shark Tank" put EverlyWell
on the map,
and now we're transforming
healthcare in America.
When I pitched on "Shark Tank,"
I had done $2.5 million
in sales.
In just two years
since "Shark Tank,"
EverlyWell has done
$65 million in sales.
EverlyWell kits are now
available in over 2,000 stores,
at major brands,
like Target and CVS.
With all this growth,
we've decided to invest
in a major re‐brand,
and Lori's coming by to weigh in
on some
of the potential changes.
I like this one because
there's a heart,
which, to me,
symbolizes health.
Greiner:
I love health and wellness,
so when Julia came into the
Shark Tank with in‐home testing
and she was so credible
and so smart, I said, "I'm in."
We're excited to get this
out into the world.
Well, the world's loving it
so far.
Yes, yes! [ Laughs ]
I think EverlyWell is on track
to become
one of my top success stories
in "Shark Tank" history.
When Julia hit
$65 million in sales,
it took my "Shark Tank" family
past a huge milestone
that we are super excited about.
I have a big surprise
for you!
Really?
I do.
[ Cheering ]
My "Shark Tank" investments
have collectively done
$1 billion in retail sales.
Let's party!
[ Cheering ]
MacKugler:
Lori is a rock star!
She's helped us
absolutely explode.
Hopper: I was Lori's
very first deal on "Shark Tank,"
and I'm so stoked to be part
of the billion‐dollar family.
We've done $18 million
in sales.
$30 million!
$40 million!       $40 million!
$50 million!
$52 million!
$175 million!      $175 million!
$233 million!
$1 billion in retail sales!
This is everything that I,
as a Shark, live for.
I am so proud of all of them,
and, hey,
my hard work has paid off, too.
Together: $1 billion!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a way for everyone
to cool down in the summer heat.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
My name is Bunim Laskin.
I am from Lakewood, New Jersey,
and I am seeking $300,000
in exchange
for 5% of my company...
Wow.
...Swimply.
Global warming.
Am I right, Sharks?
It's an epidemic
that is sweeping our planet.
The global surface temperature
is increasing
by over 1.6 degrees Fahrenheit
across the board,
and it's only going to
get hotter.
What if I told you
that I had a solution?
Introducing...
Swimply.
[ Laughter ]
Corcoran: My God.
It's him?!
[ Laughs ]
Well, Sharks, maybe I haven't
found a solution
for global warming just yet.
But I did find an amazing way
for all of us to get together
and make the world
just a little bit cooler.
Swimply is the first‐of‐its‐kind
online marketplace
for pool sharing,
where anyone can book
their own private pool
by the hour
whenever they want
from people who own a pool
but don't use it too often.
So, say you're like
my good friend Jesse.
Jesse's like most Americans
and can't afford
his own private pool.
All he has to do is visit
our website or app,
find a pool, lock it in,
and just like that,
Jesse's booked himself
the perfect poolside day,
and pool owners can now monetize
their pool's downtime,
even make a profit.
Swimply is quite literally
throwing the biggest pool party
the world has ever known,
and you're all invited.
[ Laughs ]
Which one of you will be
the first to jump in?
I'm not getting in
with that guy.
Wait, is this
really for real?
It's for real.
He's happy!
Basically, you're like
Airbnb for pools.
Exactly.
So, is the app alive
on the App Store?
The app's alive.
So, how many downloads
do you have,
how many users,
how much revenue?
Okay.
And how many pools
do you have?
And who in the world thought
this was a good idea?
I'm ‐‐ Me. So ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
The story behind Swimply
is actually a personal solution
for me.
My next‐door neighbor built
a pool for her grandkids,
and they didn't show up as much
as maybe
the grandmother supposed,
and the pool was always empty.
I sort of asked her
if it would be okay
if my family used their pool.
Very consciously aware
of the amount of money
she recently put into it,
she asked me if it would be okay
if my family helped her out.
‐Oh.
‐We worked out a deal.
We helped her pay
25% of her expenses,
and in exchange,
my family used her pool.
Before long, our entire block
was using the pool,
and I wanted to bring this
to as many people as possible.
I thought it was crazy when
you walked in here with this,
but now that I listen to
the story of how it occurred...
It's crazy.
What's happened?
So, tell us.
So, I put together
my bar mitzvah money,
and I launched a small website.
I went on Google Earth.
I found 80 people that had pools
and knocked on 80 of them.
Good for you
for doing that.
76 said "no,"
but we got our first "yeah."
[ Laughs ]
‐Yeah.
‐So, we got our first
four yeses,
and our four pools
quickly escalated to 32.
I raised 30 grand
to launch an MVP.
I spent the whole 30 grand
on the website,
just hiring a developer
and a designer.
So, wait. How much bar mitzvah
money did you burn initially?
10 grand.
Okay.
But initially, I raised 30 grand
to make the site not crash.
So, I launched with Swimply,
and immediately,
we did around 900 hours' worth
of reservations.
Bunim, I'm worried you're going
to spontaneously combust.
Slow down.
No, I want to see
how much faster you can talk.
You said 900 hours?
Laskin: 900 hours were booked.
So, we get our first 100 pools,
then the website.
I didn't really have the funds
to keep the operation going.
I spent that summer using that
beta to just raise 960 grand.
Greiner: Whoa! Whoa!
960 grand?!
O'Leary: What?!
What?
So, a million in total?
‐You raised $960,000?
‐Yeah.
Wow!
O'Leary: What?
How much of the company
did you have to sell
to raise that much?
Mazel tov!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐How did you do that?
I raised it
at a $6 million valuation.
How did you do that?
Wow.
A pool‐maintenance partnership
reached out to us, and ‐‐
Pool‐maintenance partnership?
A pool‐maintenance company?
How interesting.
A pool‐maintenance company that
has stores all over the country.
What have you booked
in hours, year‐to‐date?
In March 2019,
I raised 960 grand.
First thing we had to do
was develop
a proper website
that would scale.
So, this is your third time
trying to develop a proper
website, but go ahead.
This is really the first.
The first two times
were really a...
Yeah.
Yeah,
but they still count.
That was still 40 grand,
but go ahead.
Yeah. Okay.
We tried to build this app
and this website in three months
to get it out there
in time for summer.
To date,
there were malfunctions.
We got the product out there ‐‐
Corcoran: Would you take
a minute?
I just have to take a breath.
[ Inhales sharply ]
Okay, go ahead.
[ Breathes sharply ]
So, this year to date,
we booked
individual 1,600 hours.
Greiner: So, that's a lot.
Herjavec: Can you walk us
through the financial model?
Laskin: Sure.
How much do you make,
what does the pool owner
charge?
Walk us through that.
Sure.
So, at the moment,
we let our host
charge whatever they'd like,
and then the hosts set limits.
So, some will have a 5% limit,
some will have a 25% limit,
and then they can set
additional fees
for every person
after a certain amount.
And how do you get paid
from that?
We have
a double‐sided business model.
We take 15% commission
from the host,
and we charge the swimmer
an additional 10% service fee.
So 25% total?
25% total.
And how much have you made
year‐to‐date?
We did around $215,000 worth
of marketplace revenue.
That's net to you?
That's gross.
No, that's gross.
That's gross
marketplace revenue.
Our net
is around 20% of that.
So, you've made
$42,000 net revenue?
So, what's your dollar net?
Yes.
This is incredible.
You raised $1 million
for this idea.
Yeah.
That's very impressive.
Is that why you priced
the stock so very high?
Because based on your revenue,
it makes no sense.
So, it's a game of scale
and it's a game of promise
and it's a game of vision
right?
And that's exactly
what we're doing.
It's also a game of money.
Right.
Let me tell you
my thoughts, okay?
Okay.
I fly a lot,
and in the summer months,
when you fly over,
you will see pool after pool
after pool, and they're empty.
All these people own pools,
and there's nobody ever in them.
So I think that, in some ways,
you're really onto something,
but I just don't know
if I want to invest in this,
even though I think
there's a need.
So I'm sorry, I'm out.
Okay. Totally.
I have a couple of pragmatic
questions, alright?
When people show up, where do
they go to the bathroom?
When it comes to bathrooms,
hosts have two options.
Well ‐‐
The two options they have ‐‐
The people renting have
a third option ‐‐ they
just pee in the pool.
Right now, 50% of our pools do
offer a way to use a side door.
But, Bunim, what's the second
option for bathrooms?
The second option
is not offering one.
But if you don't offer one,
aren't people gonna pee
in the pool?
I think Jesse's peeing
in the pool right now.
But they are. But ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
I don't think
you've given a sense
of what someone's willing
to pay to use that pool.
Right.
And how many people
are paying?
Set us a range.
So, there's ‐‐ Right.
Corcoran: And if I ‐‐
So, I guess now
is a good time ‐‐
Whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa!
And if I can couple
a second part of that question,
do your customers
typically come back
and reuse the pool
once a week,
or is it
a one‐time event?
Okay, last year, the average
hour booked was $45 an hour.
This year,
the average was $90 an hour.
And how many people book it
for 100 bucks an hour?
Like, is there five
people coming over,
three people, two people?
So, last year, the average
amount of people per booking
was around 7.
This year, the average amount
of people per booking is 12.
I think the whole idea
is really nuts.
Maybe I'm not listening.
You're what we call
a fast talker in the business.
You think?
"Oh, yeah, yeah."
[ Laughs ]
I never met
anyone faster.
But I just don't get it.
So for all of those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay.
I can see
where this is a value.
You know, to get
12 friends together
and set up a party
at someone else's pool,
and it only cost me
300 or 400 bucks
for a Sunday fun day,
I can see that not being bad.
The challenge, though, is,
how many times can you do that?
How many kids can you get
to know about this
to throw parties together?
Right.
So, that comes down to how often
do people do this, right?
So, last year, when
the average price of the pool
was $50 an hour,
70% of our bookings
were families.
70% were families?
Wow.
In the beta.
Okay, what about 2019?
In 2019,
we had an issue.
This year,
we inserted Swimply Chat,
which allowed people
to facilitate pool parties
and stuff like that.
But the problem was, was that
we did run into technical issues
when it came
to notifying people,
that when you requested a pool
from somebody,
the person would approve it,
you wouldn't find out about it
for four hours.
That's a problem.
$300,000 for 5%.
That imputes
a $6 million valuation.
You're basically making
20 grand this year.
Around that, yeah.
Yeah, that's kind of crazy.
I know ‐‐
Okay, it may upset me
and excite you
is the fact that we had
$675,000 worth of bookings
that went through the platform.
Let me modify that.
We only capitalized
on $150,000 of it.
I can take "kind of"
out of that sentence.
It's just plain crazy.
Okay.
The valuation's nuts.
No. I'm out.
[ Scoffs ]
Our projections
for next year, right?
Yeah.
We're breaking even.
This doesn't excite you?
Our projections
for the year afterwards
is we're profiting $15 million,
and that's just the U. S.
$50 million?
Is that your gross
or the overall ‐‐
Our profits.
Your profit?
Our profits. Our gross by 2022
will be $289 million
in marketplace revenue
in the U. S. alone.
[ Laughs ]
Look, Bunim,
it's great to be excited,
right?
Mm‐hmm.
It's great to be committed.
Every great entrepreneur
has to be.
But self‐awareness has to be
a great trait, as well,
not lying to yourself.
Okay.
What we're talking about here
is that we took a product
this year,
we had three months to build.
As mentioned, there were
$675,000 worth of business
that went through the platform.
Only $150,000,
a little less than 20%,
actually was able to proceed,
and that is all, again,
not anecdotal.
This is product issues,
and it's something
that is easily solvable.
That doesn't mean
it scales.
What I'm saying is that
there is potential.
There were issues that were ‐‐
We're a tech company ‐‐
Yeah, but your price ‐‐
We are a tech company, right?
Your potential and your reality
are in two different universes.
I'm out.
Okay.
Are you sure?
Mark, hear me out.
I'm 22.
Bunim, he's out.
He's out.
I'm 22 years old.
I threw my first business
when I was in the 8th grade.
I get it.
You're a hustler, right?
The projections
is what's bothering you?
Let me just tell you,
this is ‐‐
We've created
something people want.
You know what projections
are worth?
Bupkes, right?
They're worth nothing.
Nothing.
Bunim.
Focus on the only Shark
that's left.
Who's left.
Bunim, I ‐‐
Look, when you came in here,
I thought
it was really crazy.
Mark, I think that you
can help a lot in this.
Hello?!
You got to work a deal, guys.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, Robert.
$289 million in two years?
In three years.
But growth is never ‐‐
Three years.
It's not linear.
It's just crazy.
It's almost ‐‐
These are how
start‐ups grow.
It is all about scale.
It is all about growth.
How many companies
go from zero to $289 million
in three years?
Zero.
None.
It's not zero, and we have
$675,000 of proof of concept
on 80% of our pools.
The 20% of our pools
that are optimized and managed
attract $675,000.
I can't take it anymore.
I love that ‐‐
I love your ‐‐
And that's before scale,
before insurance,
and I'm the only person
doing this right now.
I love your passion.
We have two customer service
representatives.
I love your ‐‐
This is something that we
can really blow up, guys.
O'Leary: [ Laughs ]
That's where you lost ‐‐
Okay, and if I do need help,
I am 22.
That's not an excuse.
To figure this out
and operate this business ‐‐
That's not an excuse.
Robert.
I'm not ‐‐
Not an excuse at all.
All I'm saying is I am learning
every single day.
Oh, my God.
Hey, Bunim, I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you very much.
Hey.
Hope you don't freeze
getting out of there.
[ Laughs ]
I don't regret
bringing up our projections.
They are ambitious.
That is what I'm trying to do.
That is the vision
that I'm executing on.
And if that vision
did scare them
or that wasn't something
they'd be on board for,
maybe it wasn't
a good match to begin with.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a solution to achieve
harmonious family trips.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Ha!
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Rachel Lincoln.
And my name
is Kristine Pruske,
but you can call me
Krissy.
‐Stop.
‐I just got it. No.
‐No. No.
[ Children arguing
indistinctly ]
We hail
from San Antonio, Texas.
And we are seeking $100,000
in exchange
for 33 1/3% equity
in our product,
The Space Traveler.
[ Arguing continues ]
Can you quiet down,
please?
Child: No, stop!
Don't make me
come back there!
No!
Oh, gosh.
Shark Tank,
we have a problem.
[ Sighs ]
[ Static crackles ]
Woman:
This is Mission Control.
How do you read?
Be advised ‐‐ we've encountered
disruptive life‐forms.
Over.
Requesting visuals.
Standing by, over.
Downloading visuals now,
over.
Child: Give it.
Give it.
‐It's my turn.
‐Give it.
‐Give me it.
Give me my toy.
Aah!
Give it.
Greiner:
"Disruptive life‐forms."
Stop!
Woman:
Do you have the device?
[ Arguing continues ]
Shark Tank,
we have the solution.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my Lord.
The device
has been installed.
Ah, the sweet sound
of space.
[ Static crackles ]
Life‐forms appear peaceful.
Great job, moms.
Over and out.
Mission accomplished!
[ Laughter ]
We're all guilty
of distracted driving,
especially
with kids in the car.
It can feel like you're
getting sucked into a black hole
of fighting
and distractions,
making you want
to scrub the mission.
[ Laughter ]
What kids need
is their own space.
The Space Traveler
separates your kids
while giving them
their own atmosphere.
The forecast is clear.
The Space Traveler
is on the launch pad,
ready to fuel up
and blast off!
Together: Who's ready to suit up
and take this journey with us?
[ Chuckles ]
My little carbon copies
will now disembark.
Okay.
Nice job, guys.
Cuban: Good job, guys.
Way to fight.
Greiner: Good job.
Boy: Goodbye.
O'Leary: Okay, so, does this in
any way impede the seat belt?
Can you still use the unit?
Yes.
We have seatbelt‐access
slots here,
sized to fit the seat belt.
So, a child can use it
without a booster,
just by itself,
like Margaret was doing.
You could use
the car seat, also,
and it has
latch‐access spaces,
so you could slide the latch
in there, as well.
You can use the seat belt
or the latch system.
I have a question.
How did you come up with this?
So, last summer,
we were about to take a trip,
and the kids were going to be
on the bench seat,
and I thought, "Well,
how am I going to
keep them separated?
There is just no way
that I'm going to take this,
you know, journey
with these kids fighting."
So, I thought,
"Let's start
with a collapsible
laundry hamper."
We have a photo.
We have a photo,
a collapsible laundry hamper.
Oh, my ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
That's pretty good.
So, the kids loved it,
and I thought,
"Okay, the laundry hampers
worked okay.
But let's try
a collapsible dog kennel."
[ Laughter ]
So, after that trip,
I called Rachel,
I was like,
"We have the best idea."
You're onto something.
And that's how
The Space Traveler was born.
Yes.
My daughter, Alyssa,
and my son, Jake,
they just go at it
like cats and dogs, right?
But I can see them
weaponizing it, you know...
Yes.
...where, hitting through it,
like they think
they have protection.
Right.
I mean ‐‐
We believe if you
separate them visually,
it does a lot for also
separating them physically.
And you don't have to put it
for all three kids.
You just have to separate
the middle one?
Unfortunately, they
actually will start fighting
about who gets to ride
in The Space Traveler.
Ah, that's a good sign.
And then it does fold down,
like all the others do?
‐It collapses, yes.
‐Yeah, it's collapsible.
‐It just twists down flat.
Yes. Yes.
Let's show you.
Cuban: Oh, there you go.
So, that twists around.
Herjavec: That's clever.
Right here.
That's great.
Krissy, what do you charge
for it?
So, right now,
we have two prototypes.
Uh‐oh!
O'Leary: That's it?
Ohhhh!
We're pre‐revenue?
Yes.                   Yes.
Tell us what you think you'll
charge for this one for car use.
We were thinking
about $29.99.
Yes.
And what do you think
it'll cost you to make?
About $17 to $18.
$17 to $18.
Cuban:
Oh, that's expensive.
Wow.
$17?
Yes.                        Yes.
So, guys,
what's your background?
We are both mothers,
first and foremost.
Yes.
Krissy started coming up with
the ideas about 10 years ago.
Yes. So ‐‐
Krissy, you had this
10 years ago?
No.
So, about 10 years ago,
when I became a mother,
I would find a need
for a product.
So, I started to design...
Her own products.
...my own products,
and Rachel would kind of
help me tweak it a little bit.
Oh.
And you've sold some?
So, we've had
some amazing designs,
and we've pitched them
to a couple companies
up in New York.
You know, they said
they loved the product,
but, you know,
didn't want to ‐‐
They wanted you
to pay how much?
They wanted you to put up,
like, $25,000 for it?
No. So ‐‐
Well, actually, they said
they weren't interested
in the product.
They weren't interested.
So, about a year later,
I went into
a major box store,
and I saw my product.
No!
Yes.
Did you litigate?
But the best part of the story
is, we did it again!
Yes.
We sent them a sample!
It was like a toxic
relationship.
Greiner: No.
We didn't know.
Yes!
‐No way.
‐Yes.
What did you send them?
We sent our next idea.
Which was a nap mat.
It's a nap mat
that rolls into a pillow.
Yes.
And it looks
like a stuffed animal.
And it looked like
a stuffed animal.
And we actually sent them
the sample.
Why?
And what happened?
I think you need to
stop sending things.
Well, we learned
our lesson.
So, Krissy, Rachel, I want to
thank you for coming today.
You can leave.
We'll knock it off.
[ Laughter ]
Perfect!
But why would you, after they
allegedly stole your idea ‐‐
why would you send them
another one?
That's a really good
question.
[ Laughter ]
It is.
It's a really good question.
We gave them the benefit
of the doubt.
Yes.
You know, people
have great ideas ‐‐
Well, that's more
than a benefit.
Alright,
I have to tell you, I ‐‐
I love your guys' story.
I thought it was
a very good presentation.
[ Smacks lips ]
I don't like this product.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
I think my kids would drive each
other nuts hitting each other.
I'm out.
Okay, we appreciate that.
Yes, thank you.
So, we see the future
of The Space Traveler
for licensing ‐‐
character licensing.
Character licensing.
Possibly making it
look like a police car
or a fire truck.
Or a fire truck.
You know,
that's a cute idea.
I mean, you guys
obviously are creative.
Your presentation was adorable.
The problem for me
as an investor,
you're so new, it's a prototype.
Mm‐hmm.
You've not had any sales
or any response at all
from the public.
So, for those reasons,
I'm sorry, I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
We appreciate that.
Thank you.
Guys, I did a deal
with a company called
Under the Weather.
Yes.
And it looks just like
their product.
The challenge is,
there's patents on
a lot of pieces there.
Yes.
Have you done
patent searches
to make sure you don't conflict
with any existing patents?
Not yet.
No.
We have a provisional patent
on it in place.
In place.
I think it'd be a conflict.
So, for those reasons, I'm out.
Thank you.
Congrats, though.
Krissy, Rachel,
you have a great idea.
I almost want to say to you
send it to the guys
that ripped you off.
At least you'll see it
in the market.
[ Laughter ]
Look, it's not a journey
I want to take with you guys.
You're very nice.
I wish you good luck,
but I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
I'll tell you what
you're reminding me of so much,
is we had two crazy guys,
brothers, last year...
Mm‐hmm.
...and they pitched
a stupid product
that I didn't even get.
It was a Comfy ‐‐
Yes.
It's a sweatshirt/blanket
with a hoodie.
Yes.
And I didn't get the product,
but I liked the guys...
Uh‐huh.
...and nobody wanted to invest,
there was no proven sales.
So for all the reasons Lori
didn't like it, I love it.
And The Comfy today,
with my help,
are doing $150 million
in sales.
Yes.
I happen to think you're
gonna sell a ton of these,
but I have to make money
right away.
Understood.
So, I'll give you exactly
what you asked ‐‐
$100,000 for 33 1/3%,
but I want a royalty of $2
for every sale,
but the royalty goes away
the minute I recoup
my investment.
Okay.
But I'll take you
from where you are now
to production.
Okay.
You'll have the right website,
the right name...
Yes.
...and you'll have
a non‐naive partner,
which you just really need.
Yes.
Yeah.
Because I've been used, abused,
and I got over it
by the time I was 30.
So nobody will use
or abuse you anymore.
Yes.
Thank you.
You should say yes
right now.
Yes.
[ Cheers and laughter ]
Thank you so much.
Thank you very much.
‐Thank you.
‐Nice to have you.
Yeah. We'll make a lot of money
right on "Shark Tank."
Okay. Yes. Awesome.
We did it!
Pruske: Going into the Tank
with just a prototype,
we knew it was risky,
and it was amazing to see
that Barbara
also believed in us
just as much as we've
always believed in each other.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is an easier way
to achieve
authentic Italian flavor.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Andy Bert.
This is my brother Eric.
We're seeking $120,000
in exchange for 10%
of our company, Bertello.
[ Italian accent ]
Sharks, do you like a‐pizza?
[ Laughter ]
Sharks, you know
what's even worse
than what my grandfather Vinny
would think
about my fake
Italian accent‐a?
[ Normal voice ] It's the
quality of home‐baked pizza
in a conventional oven!
I mean, let's be honest ‐‐
it's complete garbage!
Now, imagine baking
authentic, Neapolitan‐style,
wood‐fired pizza
at over 900 degrees
in your own backyard.
Introducing Bertello Wood Fire
& Gas Outdoor Pizza Oven.
Our oven has
multiple fuel options.
You can use
the propane burner attachment
or you can use
wood kindling.
What?!
[ Laughter ]
That's not all, Sharks.
You can also use
lump charcoal.
What?!
But wait!
There's more!
You can use wood pellets.
Herjavec: Ah.
Corcoran: Wow.
What?!
And with our
patent‐pending design,
you can use wood with gas
at the same time.
What?!
So, Sharks, next time
someone asks you
to take a bite
out of a frozen pizza
or a take‐and‐bake pizza
cooked in a home
conventional oven,
forget about it!
‐Ohh!
‐[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
So, Sharks,
let's do a deal.
Capisce?
‐Oh, my God.
‐What?!
What?!
Are you gonna do the pitch
like that?
Very good, very good.
Great bad theater.
Very good bad theater.
Cuban: Can we eat?
‐Wow.
‐Can we?
Oh, yes, please,
help yourself, and ‐‐
Yeah. You guys, eat.
What am I, chopped liver?
Where's my pie?
We would like to
invite you up, Kevin...
Oh, thank you.
...Mr. Wonderful,
to cook a pizza with us.
Are you gonna
clean up a bit?
‐Oh, my gosh.
‐Yeah, are you cleaning up?
Alright.
Am I gonna make a pie?
Is that the idea?
‐Yes. Yes.
Wow, that's really good.
Corcoran: Oh, my gosh.
Really good.
It is good.
See how I'm doing this?
Out of the skill ‐‐
Spread it out on the back.
A little bit more.
Now, I want to put
a little cheese on it.
Pepperoni's great.
Andy:
Thank you very much.
Parmesan.
Gonna put some pepperoni
down on here.
Alright. Oops.
So you're gonna want
to shake it back and
forth to get it moving.
Don't worry.
I'm skilled at this.
Alright.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Oh, beautiful.
So, how long am I waiting
to take my pie out?
You want to rotate it
every 20 to 30 seconds.
I already know that.
Alright.
How many minutes per pizza?
Up to 2, max.
Yeah.
2 max?
2 minutes?
What?!
Corcoran: Great for a party.
O'Leary: I think
I'm almost done, right?
Yeah, you can rotate it.
Thank you.
You're burning it!
Greiner:
He should've rotated it.
I like a little carbon
with my pizza.
[ Laughter ]
Nothing wrong
with that.
Yeah.
Now, that's what
I'm talking about.
Beautiful.
Is that done?
A matter
of preference.
Good job, Kevin.
O'Leary: Thank you.
I'm taking this with me.
Robert's eaten his entire one.
‐Nice.
‐It was so good.
‐This is really good.
‐Yeah.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Really, really, really good.
Eric:
Awesome. Thank you.
Is there anything on the market
like this now?
We do have
one competitor,
but they do not have
the ability
to use wood with gas
at the same time,
and they don't have
as many fuel options as us.
What's the advantage of using
wood and propane,
as opposed to just wood
or just propane?
Eric: So, with the propane,
you can preheat the oven.
So you just heat the oven up
five minutes
before you're gonna cook...
Mm.
Got it.
....throw some wood in,
...get the flame rolling.
It's just faster.
Yeah, faster and easy.
Greiner: Is this allowed
to be used indoor?
I would not generally
recommend using it indoor.
It would be similar
to using a gas grill inside.
Herjavec:
How much does it cost?
It's $250.
That's it?
What does it cost you to make?
$84 landed.
‐Wow.
‐Oh.
Cuban:
What's your net margin?
Our net is $33.
So, guys, where are you selling
it, how much have you sold?
We're selling on Amazon.
Okay.
This year,
we've done $640,000.
Wow.
We've done $400,000
in the last three months.
Cuban: Good for you.
So, how much money
have you guys invested?
Have you taken any
outside investors, any debt?
We have probably
$90,000 into it.
We borrowed $70,000 at
the beginning of the year
and just paid
all of that back.
That's the inventory
you funded?
Wow. Good for you.
Yeah, for inventory.
Is it just the two of you
alone in the business?
Yes.
So 50/50 partners?
80/20.
What's the story?
You guys chefs?
Yeah, so, I'm actually
a licensed structural engineer.
Ah, that makes sense.
I've been working
in Manhattan for 10 years
doing bridge design
and bridge inspections.
So, I'd climb to the top
of all the biggest bridges
around Manhattan.
You'd climb
to the top of them?
Wow.
Climb to the top.
Verrazzano, Queensboro Bridge,
Williamsburg,
Manhattan Bridge.
Dang.
Andy: I'm in finance.
Right out of college,
I went down,
I worked in the biggest
open outcry trading pits.
Since then,
moved back to Minnesota.
Wife, kids, and work in
financial services.
So, did you
actually design this,
or did you have someone else
do it with you?
I designed it.
I did everything.
What's been the largest obstacle
you've had to overcome?
Really, it's just keeping up
with the demand.
That's a good problem
to have.
A nice problem.
Yeah.
[ Chuckles ]
So, we would have to wait to get
money from our current order
to put money down
for the next order.
Why would you want to build
your own pizza oven
when there's at least five
that I know exist?
What is the personal motivation
to say,
"Forget the five that are
already in the market,
I'm going to go and try
and get share with a new one"?
Yeah, no, I go for it.
I think big.
When I was 10 years old, I
started building a tree house,
and I made probably
the biggest tree house
in the entire
United States.
You're an engineer.
Did you really?
Greiner: By yourself?
It's like an Ewok village.
Andy: It was awesome.
It's massive.
I worked on it from age 10
until I was like
23 years old.
Oh, wow.
[ Laughs ]
Which discipline ‐‐
That's dedication.
That's being all‐in.
Eric: Yeah.
‐No, I mean, I go overboard.
‐There's a 13‐year tree house.
And I look back at it now,
and I realize
I have a certain quality.
I just get super passionate
about whatever I do,
and I'm ‐‐
I'm obsessed with this.
Guys, look, what you've
accomplished is great.
Your margins are good,
you're selling through.
The challenge is, you're still
just a consumer product.
It's just not a business I just
want to get attached to.
I'm not that guy who, like,
"Let's heat up the grill,"
you know, "and let's go make
some pizza in the backyard."
So, it's just not a fit for me,
so for those reasons, I'm out.
No problem.
Thank you, Mark.
Congrats, guys.
When you came out,
I was really excited.
Obviously, I love the pizza.
[ Laughs ]
But I don't know ‐‐
I'm sitting here,
I'm not excited about it,
for some reason.
I don't know whether it's
there's so much competition.
I'm not seeing the connection
between the Andy and Eric
pizza show,
the oven, and how you're going
to go to mass market.
And for that reason, I'm out.
Corcoran: I think it's
a beautifully designed oven,
but I'll tell you what
I can't get here.
When you did
your dog‐and‐pony show,
I mean, we were, like,
jumping in our seat,
and then you got hit
with a pizza,
and then everything changed.
Yeah.
Are you still recovering
from that?
[ Chuckles ]
Maybe a little bit.
What's happened?
‐Your energy really went...
‐Yeah.
No, really,
what's happened?
I'd love you to address that,
because that's
my main point of concern.
♪♪
Narrator:
Two Sharks are out.
Barbara may be interested
in Eric and Andy's
wood‐fired pizza oven, Bertello,
but she is concerned
about their lack of energy.
No, really, what's happened?
I'd love you to address that,
because that's
my main point of concern.
Oh, yeah, no,
I'm super energetic, but ‐‐
Really?
Um ‐‐ Yeah, absolutely.
Even the way you said that
wasn't energetic.
[ Laughter ]
I'm super energetic!
Do you want me
to talk like this?
Yeah, that's it!
That's a boy.
I'll talk like this.
I can talk like this.
Yeah.
No, but now it feels
like an act.
I know.
Before, it felt like you.
Now it feels like an act.
‐It's bad theater.
‐Aw.
‐But what about that?
I mean, I'm matching the tone
and energy of the room.
Barbara, what he's saying is,
you're putting him to sleep.
[ Laughter ]
No, I mean, I love ‐‐
It's an odd thing
because usually
I'll buy into products
that I'm not that crazy
about the product...
Yep.
...and I love
the entrepreneur...
Yeah.
...and I do very well
with it.
I've never been mistaken
when I follow my heart
on the entrepreneurs.
But I really ‐‐ I don't think
I've ever been
in a position
where I love the product ‐‐
I live, eat, sleep, and breathe
this ‐‐ this pizza oven.
‐I bet.
‐Yeah.
I, uh, work on this
seven days a week, 24/7.
I happen to think it would do
very well in retail.
It doesn't take up
a lot of space...
Yeah.
...the price point is good,
it looks luxurious.
I'm absolutely open
to that option.
Okay, I'll give you
an offer.
We've been to bes‐‐
I'll give you the $120,000,
but I need 25%.
♪♪
Could you do ‐‐
O'Leary:
I also have an offer.
I'd get behind this
as Chef Wonderful
and sell a lot of it,
'cause I'm an amazing chef.
Ugh.
But I want more.
Um, really, it's you, Eric,
and a bunch of money
required for inventory,
and probably more optimization
on digital
that you've never done.
Okay.
But I want 30%.
If I get behind this,
the numbers will be up tenfold.
Would you do it for 25%?
Yes.
Whoa ‐‐
We would love to take
your deal.
‐What?!
‐Let's do it.
‐Whoo!
‐I don't believe it!
Thanks, guys.
I won't step in that.
I got to be careful.
Herjavec: Wow.
Congratulations, guys.
Thank you very much.
Let's do it.
Wha‐‐
Yes! Yes!
Yes! Yes! Yes!
You like that?!
Whoo!
We got the same offer
from Barbara and Kevin,
but we went with Kevin
because he believed in us
from the start,
and he made an offer
right away.
Barbara wasn't sure.
Barbara, you said to him
he had no energy.
Hard to get a deal
when you call somebody boring.
Well,
you're right about that,
but that proves that they
didn't recover from that.
I like engineers.
I hope you lose
all your money.
your money.
Why are you being
so mean, Barbara?
I'm being mean 'cause
I'm annoyed. That's why.
Watch your hand, buddy.
It's really hot now.
You didn't see this
in the ‐‐
Greiner: Oh, whoa!
Corcoran: Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Robert, be careful.
‐It's really, really cool.
‐Oh!
Robert, Robert, lift that
off the counter!
Watch out! You're
burning the counter!
Take it off the counter!
Lift it up!
Pee on it, Robert!
Pee on it!
Corcoran: Really.
Oh, my God.
[ Shrieks ]
[ Laughs ]
Is there a nice,
big, black stain?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪